dreams may not die
but sometimes they are
reborn
[Music]
so a number of folks have been asking me
for a little bit now hey have you
watched netflix's sandman yet you're
gonna do a review for netflix's sandman
and um now i'm gonna do this instead
which is going to serve as kind of a
review but honestly i realized as it was
finishing up i have a lot more to say
than just
i liked it this was good or i didn't
like it this was bad
i've got a lot more complicated feelings
on this particularly in terms of how it
is as an adaptation
because
i went into this openly
nervous
i was actually increasingly skeptical as
not only the trailers but like little
behind the scene snippets neil gaiman
talking as that stuff was coming out i
was getting more and more and more
nervous
i am happy to say
that i'm very happy with this series and
it's an excellent
adaptation
i'm not going to say it was wrong to be
nervous though because that had to do
with how it was marketed and a lot of
the marketing put a
lot
of emphasis on how faithful to the
original work it was
now this shot it's exactly the same shot
as the comics although it is flipped
that had me very worried
because well a number of reasons one
i like the original a lot and it's very
much tailored to the medium it was
originally told in if you want to know
how that can impact things i did a
lengthy breakdown of zack snyder's
watchman movie which is
badly flawed largely because of how much
it pulls directly from the comics when
it's pulling moments that were designed
to work on the page and
they just don't work as well in the new
medium so that's part of why i was
nervous in addition to that we've
already had a super loyal adaptation in
the form of the audible audio dramas
which i've also reviewed you can check
that out there well i've reviewed the
first one i haven't gotten to the second
one yet i'm trying to catch up on some
other stuff
but
my point is that
the idea of a super loyal adaptation of
this
i actually didn't have a lot of interest
in that and because all the marketing
was putting all the emphasis on hey look
this shot is pulled directly from the
comics oh here's a line in the trailer
that's exactly the line from the comics
and i was getting very nervous tell us
what power of dreams
i was getting very nervous that this was
going to be more interested in being
loyal than being well adapted
that is not the case
this is fantastically
adapted it does in my mind what any
adaptation of a work like this should do
which is
whenever something isn't necessarily
going to work in the new medium
you change it
whenever you come across something that
uh you know what maybe that wasn't the
best choice originally or maybe that
aspect hasn't aged well
you change it
whenever you come across something
that's like you know we could just do
something a little bit different that
doesn't fundamentally alter it but just
gives it a slightly different flavor
you do that
but you also keep
a lot of the specifics you keep a lot of
the exact dialogue where it makes sense
to do so you keep some of the same exact
visuals but you take opportunities to do
other things it's been treated
or like in conversation it gets treated
like a zero sun game either well you
just throw the original out and do your
own thing or you are super loyal to the
word
no the best stuff falls in the middle
and this is a really good adaptation
because that is exactly what it does now
short version is i like this a lot
it is good in the same ways that the
original comic was good but it does the
necessary alterations to come up to the
times to work better in the medium it's
in to not lean on some stuff that it
just isn't able to do and i will get
into more specifics about what i mean by
all that
but i'm just saying this up front
because
i'm gonna get into spoilers pretty much
right off the bat because i want to talk
nuts and bolts about the ways in which
this was adapted and the ways in which
these decisions were very smart
decisions for the new medium that they
were working in
even sometimes when they were decisions
where their hands were probably forced
in one way or another
but i want to talk about that openly and
i don't want to have to try and figure
out how to dodge around that and you
know i'll do spoilers later no
i'm talking
everything we see in here so what that
means spoiler-wise is spoilers for this
season of the show which also because
this is what gets adapted that means i'm
also going to be talking spoilers for
the first two volumes of the comic
itself so that's preludes and nocturns
and the doll's house
so if you have never read those if you
haven't seen the thing yet like i'm just
going to be talking about this stuff
openly so be aware i think it's good
i think you should see it okay
here we go
in terms of specific adaptational
changes one thing that i'm basically not
going to dwell on is any alterations in
race or gender
i know that's something that some people
have decided to not only at the time of
casting announcements but like still up
to now make a big deal about the fact
that a black woman is playing death a
woman is playing lucifer a woman is
playing a different version of
constantine it's not even john
constantine etc etc
none of this i'm gonna dwell on because
i think they cast good actors who play
the roles well none of these alterations
are actually core to who these
characters were as people as characters
as far as i am concerned
so
that i'm not even going to dwell on i'm
simply going to acknowledge that i'm not
going to dwell on it
but
as it was going forward i found myself
catalogued because i know i know these
comics
quite well like i need to emphasize i
really like
sandman comics
but as it was moving forward
picking up on the things that were
different
or new
became one of my favorite things about
it
but it wasn't like
ooh they changed it why'd they change
that it was like ooh they changed that
that's interesting because like i said
if it had been a one for one
i would have been very bored
i would have been incredibly bored and
really frustrated and very disappointed
but it wasn't and also let me be clear
when i talk about this being an
excellent adaptation i mean of the kind
of story it is
when it comes to different types of
stories you can do that adaptation
different ways so like for example i
actually think the marvel movies are
pretty decent adaptations because
they're taking characters that have been
running for so long
that they rarely adapt specific stories
beyond anything more than just the
broadest strokes what they focus in on
is adapting the characters well not so
much about the stories and i think for
that it's a good approach here you need
to adapt the story because like it's a
story about stories it's a story about
why stories matter
so
you kind of need to focus in and know
what you're doing
and this does the first major thing that
i noted was that the corinthian gets
introduced pretty much immediately
in the comics he does not come into play
until the second volume until the doll's
house
he i think gets referenced prior to that
but he does not appear he shows up
almost immediately here and his presence
is reasserted at a few points
this is
very smart
now normally i'd say you're
begging you're bringing him up as a
villain more than is necessary why are
you doing that no i knew exactly why
they were doing that
because whereas the volumes of the comic
were an ongoing thing and did not have
to necessarily have a big massive climax
at the end of things in fact some things
are very much deliberately anti-climaxes
actually the defeat of the corinthian in
the comics is kind of a deliberate
anti-climax in a lot of ways they build
it up a bit more here because the nature
of the medium the nature of television
the nature of a continuing story you're
telling over multiple episodes ending at
the end of a season that may or may not
get more after this needs a stronger
climax than what was designed in the
comics
and so things are done at the end to up
the threat of the corinthian
because of some of the other stuff that
he does that is new like the way in
which he
gets hold of and tries to utilize rose
walker
that's new
but introducing him earlier also
gives us a steady build
to him and it makes it feel more like a
continuing story as opposed to
five episodes that tell a pretty
complete story of dream being captured
freed and then retrieves tools
four episodes at the back end telling
the story of rose walker the vortex and
how the corinthian gets dealt with and
one episode in between those two arcs as
as a bit of a buffer
instead of that by putting the
corinthian
in earlier
and giving us reminders having him be a
presence
it makes it feel
more like a continuous piece than it
would have in a more loyal adaptation
then i also mentioned and alluded to
there's some stuff that i think they
really had no option but to alter it
because of wright's stuff now you have
to remember that sandman in the comics
originally was in the dc universe proper
i think technically he was all the way
through but like overall it actually
meant something in the beginning like
the character of john d in the comics is
dr destiny who was an established
villain
the facility he's held in in the comics
is arkham asylum scarecrow makes an
appearance there are appearances by the
martian man hunter there's john
constantine here reimagined as joanna
constantine there is things that go on
with the original sandman hector hall
all completely reimagined done over in
different ways i'll come back to hector
and lida hall in a little bit but
all these things probably had to be
changed because of rights issues because
when you are licensing out the rights to
neil gaiman sandman
these other characters appeared in it
but they were not created for it so they
require separate licenses if you're
going to include them not to mention the
fact that i think your average uh
watcher of the tv show would have been
incredibly confused
if scarecrow or the martian mayor and
man hunter or even john constantine
showed up
so
those changes were probably largely
required by not needing to license the
rights to more than just the sandman
stories but they're still well handled
they're still well adapted joanna
constantine is
effectively a feminized version of john
constantine not
completely like
jenna coleman is able to bring in a
little bit of her own flavor as a
performer where it doesn't just feel
like she's
being the same character straight up but
she bears a similar backstory she's
filling a very similar function and i
think she works well
i think it's worth noting at this point
i think
pretty much all the performances are
quite good including the ones that i was
paranoid i wouldn't like so again
if you watch some of my earlier stuff i
was paranoid that i wasn't going to like
the corinthian or desire which were two
performances i didn't particularly care
for in the audiobook adaptation and the
reason is very
self-centered and it's a performer's
problem which is that
those are both parts
that i would like to play
and since those are characters i would
like to play i tend to be very
judgmental of someone who did get to
play them because part of my brain is
liable to go i could have done that
better
and i didn't feel that about either of
them neither desire nor the corinthian
left me going i could have done that or
i could have done that even better
i did feel that a little bit with the
audiobook but i didn't feel that here
with this
i think they were both well done
the show was very smart about what sort
of flavor moments it chose to keep so
like for instance cain and abel appear
now cain and abel are kind of iconic if
you've read the sandman but narratively
they don't really
need to be there
they don't really matter
kane will matter a little bit later on
assuming that further stories get
adapted but
between the two of them they're just
always kind of there they they are
flavor to the dreaming
and they're here
because they are appropriate flavor for
the kinds of inhabitants
that are there now i did note that they
kept those two they did not carry over
eve
and probably if i were to guess why if i
were to try and explain to you eve as a
actual character as a personality
from the comics i i don't have a lot
she doesn't stick in your head
the way cain and abel do
but
those two
you'd very much feel their absence
if they weren't there as a fan of these
things so keeping them
makes an awful lot of sense
but there's also some alterations to
characters that i think
had nothing to do
with anything related to rights or
anything like that that were just
changes
that it was decided this would be a good
idea
one was an expansion of a character who
if i remember he doesn't really appear
at all
and is really only referred to and
another is a consolidation of two
characters into one new character
so the first is ethyl crypts
that is the woman who
steals
all the stuff from the magus who had
captured dream and who later gives birth
to john d and passes on the ruby to him
she's effectively a non-character she's
referred to in the original but she
doesn't appear
here
giving her a personality
letting us see her
with john before his escape from the
facility that he's being held in gives
us a chance to
get a sense of him through her
and it helps us
relate to john even before we get to
know him i say relate not necessarily
sympathize or empathize with
because i'll kind of come back to that
but uh the other character who's a
consolidation and amalgamation is galt
who is a nightmare a shape-shifting
nightmare missing from the dreaming
she's missing along with the corinthian
and fiddler's green now the corinthian
and fiddler's green are in the comics in
the comics though there's no galt
instead there is brute and glob who
don't really matter and never come back
after this particular story
and i think it was a wise idea to
consolidate
their
narrative function into a single new
character
who could be used to put some strain on
lucian and dream's relationship
to kind of force them into a conflict
that was i think understandable and to
have her return mark a little bit of a
shift
in morpheus in dream
so i think that was a really wise idea
because i don't know anyone who would
have been clamoring for brute and glob
to come back
now
i said i'd come back to john d
there's a lot of very small
but very smart
changes two characters that alter the
way
that the audience is going to connect
and relate to them
so with john
there's the whole thing with rosemary
who picks him up off the road
drives him to where he wants to go
in the comics she's nice
she drops him off
and he shoots her
and i remember watching as he reached
into his
jacket and i expect him to pull out a
gun he was going to shoot her he didn't
he pulled out the protection
necklace that he had and he gave that to
her
now for fans like me who already know
the comics this is like that's an
interesting change and for people who
don't know what's coming next
it sets you up for a massive gut punch
because the episode after this
is 24 7.
and that episode is a pretty loyal
adaptation of the issue of that comic
by taking that change and not having
john kill rosemary you start to think
oh he doesn't seem like that bad a guy
and like up to that point the people
that he had killed were all people who
had tried to shoot him tried to hurt him
he was effectively acting in
self-defense
so you start to think
maybe he's not that bad
and then we get to 24 7
where he goes into the diner and
makes people
be honest
be who they truly are
and then push that
much further than they would ever
be
to get
the worst
and the cruelest
outcome
that he can
and that whole thing is unsettling no
matter what but i think it i think it
makes it hit harder
that instead of a glimpse at his cruelty
by killing rosemary we get a glimpse of
kindness
to then be followed by this
a number of other small things which
work as very wise adaptational choices
so
the serial convention there's the
character of fun land
and funland is a
child murderer definitely
child molester possibly
it's implied
but
in the comics
he's dealt with
unsettlingly
gently
here he's just killed
which is much
much more appropriate for who this guy
is and what he does
he was kind of treated with kid gloves
in the comic i think because he himself
was kind of childlike but like
he kills kids
i don't care if he's childlike
he should not have been handled as
softly and delicately as he was in the
comics and this seems to agree because
they just kill him
good
by a similar token
we have alex who is the person who is
more or less in charge
of the place where dream has been held
for well in this version over a hundred
years because they moved the timeline up
uh to match with actual time that that
things are now happening
and
in the comics dream is
quite cruel now dream still punishes him
in the show
but he
gives him the gift of i believe he calls
it eternal sleeping what he does to him
in the comic
is to give him eternal waking
because you ever have that thing
where you're in a nightmare let me be
clear not a dream a nightmare
and you think you wake up
and then realize you're still in the
nightmare
that's what dream did to alex in the
comics and he did it to him
forever
and given that alex was not the guy who
actually put him in that cage he did
not release him so like i get some level
of vengeance but it always did seem a
little bit crueler than maybe it should
have been
and this goes just a little softer
which again feels like a wise
adaptational choice especially because
just by virtue of having dream be played
by a human being he's going to be a
little bit more humanized because in the
comics the way he's drawn especially in
the face and the eyes is a bit more
off-putting than you're going to get
from frankly any human actor unless you
do some serious cgi augmentation which
they did not opt to do
i mentioned uh moving forward the
timeline which i which was an
interesting choice
that was something that i actually would
have said they didn't need to do they
could have just made this a period piece
and have it set uh the bulk of it in the
80s which was when the comic was going
out at the time for the chunk of the
comics that this covers i think they
could have perfectly gotten away with
that and just kept the timelines as is
etcetera etcetera
but
they don't they move things forward and
that gives us little things like
the small alteration
to
the regular meetings between dream
and hob
where in the comics
dream never misses their appointment
in this one he does by necessity because
of how long he now has been locked up
with the altered timeline because
they're still keeping him being captured
in 1916 that you can't really move
because they tie it to the sleeping
sickness which was an actual thing that
happened so you actually can't really
move that but if they're moving his
point of freedom way later
by about
40 years a little less than 40.
35-ish i don't know i can't remember
what year the first issue came out you
know 30 some odd years
forward yeah no he's missing that
appointment
and what was funny to me is how little
they had to actually change to
acknowledge that
i've always heard it in polite to keep
one's friends waiting
that's the same line in the comics
it's just the differences this time he
is genuinely years late he wasn't in the
comics
but that acknowledgement of hob as a
friend
is still there
as it should be and actually i think
that episode is my favorite episode
because they
blend together
the introduction of death
as a character
and
she's beautifully done
i thought
and we have that
and
then have that bleed over
into hob and having her as kind of the
bridging point for that makes sense and
then
watching
dream reconnect getting the backstory of
him and hob and then seeing him
reconnect after having had this
conversation with his sister death
putting those two in the same space
works
shockingly well
i would have thought they were a little
too isolated self-contained but no they
work
shockingly well both of them
some other small adaptational changes
that really feel like strong concessions
to the new medium it's in
despair
we don't see a lot of her
but
in the comics so like if you've only
seen the show despair is you know kind
of
you know in a dumpy sweater you know she
she looks like someone who
who hasn't left their apartment in a
while they they are too sad to leave the
house
in the comics she's naked
all the time
and i actually do think it works in the
comics the way that her
uh her appearance and her nakedness is
done is
something that feeds into her portrayal
as a character and for me it never
really came across as exploitative and
it's certainly not drawn to be
titillating
but
the thing is by
taking not a piece of art not a very
exaggerated despair is
uh
very malformed in a lot of ways and
there's a conversation to be had about
whether that is
ableist er i and i'm not really sure i
want to go there i will say at least to
the best of my knowledge her physical
shape especially combined with like
what's going on with her jaw and some
other stuff in the comics again
does not appear to be like a direct
correlation to any conditions at least
that i know about
but again that's kind of a separate
conversation but what i will say is that
you know she's drawn that way to a very
specific effect in the comics
that would not have played the same if
they'd had her be naked in the show
because by virtue of having an actual
person with
you know
even someone you know with a
similar body shape to despair in the
comics
just having an actual person be naked as
opposed to this abstracted concept as
she is in the comics
it gives it an entirely different feel
because it's lacking the distancing
effect of it being artwork
and having it be a real person feels
exploitative in a way that the comics
just
don't
and so i think that was a very wise
choice to actually just
put her in clothes
now lida and hector hall actually go
through some very significant changes
again partially probably partially due
to wright's reasons with these
characters especially with hector
but
they also build up light a bit more and
they give light a
more of a sense of truly clinging to
this because like in the comics light
has just been in the dreaming with
hector for
decades
and how aware she is of it is a little
bit up and down but that's kind of just
been her life
whereas here
hector is something she's already lost
so when she finds him in the dreaming
this is something she's regaining and i
think that is a way to make her
anger towards dream for taking that away
from her something that she's already
gone through the loss of and she thought
she could have again when he takes that
away from her her anger
makes a bit more sense not that her
anger was unjustified in the comics but
it gives you a stronger anchor and given
what goes on with her later on assuming
they get to adapt it i think that's a
good strong choice
now i'm going through praising all these
alterations and all these changes there
was one
there was one choice that i'm not sure
why they did it and i think it was a
mistake
and that has to do with lucifer
so
in the comics
when dream goes to hell to retrieve his
helm and he confronts korinson who has
his helm and he challenges him to
quote-unquote the oldest game
in the show
cornzone names
lucifer as his champion
so dream has to then confront
lucifer
in the comics he just confronts corunzen
now lucifer oversees it
at the end of it lucifer still
threatens dream in the same way
in a why should i let you leave manor
but the meaning is now completely
changed by having dream actually defeat
lucifer i i don't know why this change
was done i think they're trying to shore
up and firm up a
rivalry between lucifer and dream i
think it's deeply unnecessary and it
weakens lucifer as a character
because first of all
it makes lucifer seem like less of a
threat
if dream has effectively already
defeated him him them i actually don't
know if they used pronouns for lucifer
in this
i'm going with them
[Laughter]
but
to see that dream is already defeated it
all it already lessens the
sense of
danger how dangerous are now granted
it's an atypical confrontation but it
feels like it undercuts the idea that
lucifer is significantly more powerful
than dream
that's the first problem
the second is it makes that moment when
lucifer says why should we let you leave
it takes that and turns it from
a moment of just oh right this is the
devil we can't trust them
which is what it is in the comics
because lucifer is very polite
very
accommodating you know doing the whole
well there are rules there are
procedures but is very polite
at going forward and then suddenly goes
why should we let you leave and it's a
moment of oh crap right don't ever trust
them
but
in the show now because lucifer has just
barely been defeated instead it comes
across as spiteful
as petty
it doesn't come across as calculated or
like indicative of a sense of
untrustworthiness it just comes across
like being a sore loser
which
again just
feels weaker
and
that is the one alteration that i can
think of
that
i think was a mistake
every other alteration that i can think
of some of which i've talked about some
of which i haven't like i'm not going to
go through point for point i'm going
through the ones that stuck in my head
and made me think about them but all the
other adaptational changes i can think
of were either improvements
um
in some cases honestly kind of
objectively
i think uh giving us more of ethel
crypts is objectively just better
or it was a better choice for the new
medium or the times in which we now live
with alterations to things like how
dream handled alex how fun land was
dealt with introducing introducing the
corinthian earlier or worst case i felt
neutral about them that neither hurt
anything nor made it better like with a
lot of the casting alterations i don't
think that you know
having this person be a different gender
this person be a different race
i
i'm neutral on that so every adaptation
choice i mean they're like okay that's
fine or i'm like that's good or that's
interesting except for that one thing
with lucifer that is the one thing i'm
like i don't know why you did that
but i suppose for the purposes of
analysis it's helpful for me to have it
there as a point of comparison where
it's like that really kind of is the
only thing
and everything else i'm like these are
really
really smart
or interesting or well thought out
adaptational changes
and even for all these changes
this
is
the sandman
this feels like the same man this sounds
like the same man this looks like the
sandman
but
there are enough changes
that i can watch it and
as someone who knows these comics
exceedingly well i can go
i wonder what will be different
and it actually excites me
to spot the small changes
and see how it plays out just a little
bit different while keeping that same
core essence
and when it goes off on slightly
different tangents in slightly different
ways
i can know and it's going to circle back
to the stuff that i love and i wouldn't
want changed and it does
it is able to dance this
dance of
i get to alternate between
what's gonna be the next change and then
when we're in changes like ooh we're
gonna get back to this bit that i love
that i know that they'll keep and they
do
what is changed
and how they change it
are incredibly well calculated well
balanced well thought out
beautiful
i hope this gets another season i was so
happy i was so happy i think
two episodes in realizing how much i was
loving this
because like i said i was skeptical
and i can be a cynical person
but i like
liking stuff
and i love
going in skeptical
and being wrong
and i was
i was wrong again i don't i think i was
justified in my skepticism based off how
it was marketed
but
that skepticism was not borne out
and i really hope we get more of this
the sandman
hopefully we'll get a season two they're
in the planning stages of it but it has
not officially been confirmed yet
what did you think of this first season
though whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it patreon
is what pays the bills and enables me to
have these conversations with you
about this stuff oftentimes you'll see
me up here complaining railing against
some industry nonsense but every now and
then i get to talk to you about
something really good
i look forward to the next time i can do
that and patreon is what supports me and
enables me to keep on doing this
but even if you can't do that i mean
there are perks at every tier of support
but
even if you can't
like share and subscribe help as well
but more than anything i want you to
remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin ludwig to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelki the
other boy becky sparks fernandi likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brendan larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards on my
patreon
now
[Music]
bye
[Music]